bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7-8 l'actu
sur tv fil 78 nous allons faire le tour
de l'actualité locale comme chaque soir
en direct à 18 heures voici les
principaux titres que nous allons
développer
bientôt la fin des tracts syndicaux
technocentre force ouvrière a ouvert
l'antenne de radio lui en cours pour
communiquer d'une autre manière le média
n'est pas diffusée directement sur les
ondes mais par podcast la découverte des
institutions locales et des droits de
l'enfant c'est le thème de la semaine de
la citoyenneté qui s'est ouverte à magny
les hameaux prévention routière
addictions notamment au programme depuis
cette semaine est aussi celle de la
science avec des animations à travers le
département
nous verrons ce que prépare la maison de
l'environnement de magny les hameaux
ainsi que l'observatoire de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
avec elle nous invite à l'image du jour
dédié à la librairie le pavé du canal à
montigny le bretonneux l'établissement
existe depuis maintenant 24 ans mais son
futur pose question développement des
ventes sur internet concurrence des
grandes surfaces coût des loyers en
centre ville
une situation qui pousse son
propriétaire organisé mercredi prochain
à 19h un rendez vous autour de l'avenir
de l'établissement il sera aussi
question de la reprise seriez vous prêt
à vous lancer dans une telle aventure à
reprendre ce commerce
à l'heure où de nombreux autres
librairies ferme définitivement leurs
portes l'avenir du pavé du canal à
montigny en question mercredi prochain
et nous recevrons bien sûr son directeur
dans les prochains jours sur cette
antenne le syndicat force ouvrière
quasiment absent au technocentre renault
de guyancourt vient de créer radio
guyancourt une radio en podcast qui
donne la parole aux salariés saint
quentinois sur des thèmes comme l'avenir
de l'industrie automobile ou le stress
au travail
anthony rech et jonathan vilma radio
guillon
la radio du technocentre avec efforts et
nos les salariés de renault vont bientôt
mettre de côté le traditionnel tract
distribué dans les allées du
technocentre
ils peuvent désormais écouter les
propositions de force ouvrière sur radio
j en cours tout en sachant qu' il ya six
organisations syndicales sur le
technocentre
c'est donc beaucoup de tracts beaucoup
de papier beaucoup de lecture
d'ailleurs je ne sais pas si tous les
salariés les lisent tous les tous les
tracts et un peu peut-être se démarquer
et aussi faire passer d'autres messages
avoir d'autres débats que l'on peut
avoir éventuellement sur une version
papier des micro trottoirs des salariés
sont réalisés chaque semaine à
guyancourt ils peuvent écouter
l'émission sur internet ou par téléphone
stress au travail à venir de
l'ingénierie automobile ou
réorganisation du technocentre
les thèmes sont débattues avec des
personnalités telles qu arnaud
montebourg ministre du redressement
productif radio guyancourt cette semaine
laurent nous allons parler
mondialisation et plus précisément poser
la question comment soutenir
l'ingénierie française face à la
mondialisation
arnaud montbourg au micro de benedikt
fischer pour radio guyancourt
tout notre travail au sein de l'union
européenne au nom du gouvernement
français c'est de réorienter l'europe
pour qu'elle abandonne sa naïveté c'est
à dire qu'elle ne soit pas elle mise à
nu pendant que les autres on en armure
en acier trempé cherono force ouvrière
est représentée au niveau national mais
pas au technocentre ou le syndicat n'a
réalisé que 2% des voix lors des
dernières élections professionnelles
pour la cgt et fo veut faire du forcing
pour exister à guyancourt
si une organisation syndicale au
technocentre ne cherche pas à faire un
peu plus d'audience c'est que je pense
qu'elle s'est trompée de créneau qu'on
fasse passer des messages par une
version papier par la version radio ou
voir vidéo mammites comme vous on
cherche toujours à faire depuis
l'audience
l'idée même de la radio c'était un moyen
aussi de laisser la parole aux salariés
la programmation est déjà établie
jusqu'à mi janvier laurence monique
espère transformer radio guyancourt en
radio rhône ont donné à une association
c'est plutôt simple mais même pas
toujours indolore pour les finances du
ménage c'est de ce constat qui est née
l'initiative de microdon sur les
transactions du quotidien vous pouvez
verser quelques centimes ou quelques
euros pour soutenir une bonne cause dans
certains supermarchés le week-end
dernier ils étaient tout de même
également possible de passer en caisse
avec un simple flyers une carte scanner
comme n'importe quel autre article du
magasin plus d'explications avec claire
cambier et anthony rech ce week-end 27
associations yvelinoise ont investi les
halls des grandes surfaces pour
l'opération micro d'eau pour la première
fois des associations de solidarité
locale participer à cet événement
solidarités nouvelles pour le logement
une association qui propose des
logements passerelle pour les personnes
en attente de logements sociaux était à
plaisir une quarantaine de bénévoles se
sont relayés pour présenter aux clients
leur association et les inciter à faire
des dos 2 2 euros ou plus voile accueil
vous est tombé sur des gens qui sont
parfois près c'est difficile de capter
mais il ya des gens qui sont tout à fait
attentifs au discours des gens qui nous
disent qu effectivement on devrait
prendre en cause c'est les choses là et
au niveau politique bon et bien on
arrive à un mission politique mais
plutôt un bon accueil et où on attend le
retour maintenant de savoir si ça se
traduit par des dons en caisse
le principe est simple pour donner il
suffit de passer ce flyer à la caisse le
don de 2 euros s'affiche sur le ticket
comme n'importe quel article
c'est très bien ça et vite
manipuler d'argent c'est plus simple
c'est très très bien faudra le faire ce
soir
l'association a finalement récolté près
de 2200 euros sur deux jours les
bénéfices permettront de financer en
partie cinq nouveaux logements
passerelle aux clayes-sous-bois depuis
lundi enfants et adolescents de magny
les hameaux participe à la semaine de la
citoyenneté prévention routière droits
des enfants aux initiations également
aux premiers secours tous ces thèmes
sont abordés afin de sensibiliser ce
jeune public et ainsi en faire de bons
citoyens le reportage d'olivier
maniscalco et d'élodie moines
portant ses lunettes
son
quelqu'un qui a vu les quantités
d'alcool pur
faire de nos enfants des citoyens
avertis et responsable c'est la mission
que s'est donnée la mairie de magny les
hameaux avec sa semaine de la
citoyenneté
le principe est simple des intervenants
accueille les enfants sur la place de
l'hôtel de ville et grâce à des
exercices ludiques
il a l'air que les petits sur les
dangers du quotidien on a appris ce qui
est chaud qu'est ce qu'il faut ce que
j'apprends on doive pas être touché
sinon que ce volet nous c'est de couper
le grille pain là bas sont enfin ça faut
pas y toucher par spéciale électriques
et des accidents domestiques droits de
l'enfant mémoire des anciens combattants
beaucoup de thèmes sont abordés comme
celui de la prévention routière où l'on
initie les futurs automobilistes aux
règles du code de la route il y à des
jeux ludiques qui ce qui montre les
circonstances de l'agglomération de la
route
on leur pose un certain nombre de
questions en groupe ils sont capables de
répondre pratiquement toutes les
questions ça leur plaît c'est leur plaît
énormément et ils en discutent entre eux
après et c'est ça qui est positif et ils
se ils se reprennent eux mêmes c'était
la première édition l'année passée
ç'a eu beaucoup de succès on a eu aussi
un retour des parents et des enseignants
qui a été très très bons donc on s'est
dit on
on refait une deuxième édition environ
250 enfants étaient présents ce mercredi
la semaine de la citoyenneté s'achèvera
samedi avec les mêmes intervenants de
10h à 17h sur la place de la mairie
nouvelle édition de la fête de la
science lancée en 1991 par le ministère
de l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche objectif favoriser les
échanges entre communautés scientifiques
et grand public des centaines
d'événements sont prévus à travers la
france jusqu'au 13 octobre 108 événement
uniquement sur la région ile de france
sont recensés notamment à magny les
hameaux pour la maison de
l'environnement représenté à ce soir sur
ce plateau
a part ça la directrice sandrine le
flohic bonsoir à vous et à vous sur ce
plateau
et puis à guyancourt l'observatoire de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines rattaché à
l'université notamment de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sa chargée de
communication est aussi l'invité du
journal ce soir bonsoir et bienvenue en
plateau l'aktu ce soir c'est donc la
fête de la science qui va nous
intéresser on va parler de vos
programmations respectives tout d'abord
un micro-trottoir pourquoi une fête de
la science allez-vous y participer que
pensez-vous de cette initiative c'est
notre question du jour peut apporter les
champs s'intéresser à des choses à
laquelle ils s'intéressent répand en
temps normal on sera là sur six l'ibook
choses dans le monde le sait très bien
et c'est intéressant la science ça
regroupe le voilà c'est
pluridisciplinaire il ya beaucoup de
discipline à l'intérieur plutôt
intéressant d'en découvrir de nouvelles
choses mais c'est toujours intéressant
de découvrir des choses nouvelles de
toute façon alors après
précisément je peux pas vous dire là
mais la curiosité est un joli défend je
pense c'est très bien pour les enfants
pour les adultes aussi probablement à
partir de là comme je n'ai vu aucune
manifestation moi je regrette un peu
vous me l'apprenez
mais je me renseignerai on va fête de la
science tout le monde trouve ça bien
mais tout le monde n'a pas forcément la
formation on espère que vous nous
regardez ce soir pour avoir un petit
aperçu du programme sur le secteur en
plateau je vous le disais de
représentants de l'ové sql
l'observatoire de versailles saint
quentin et de la maison de
l'environnement j'aimerais votre
réaction à chacune sur ce qu'on vient
d'entendre la fête de la science c'est
très bien mais on a finalement on n'en
parle pas assez on communique pas assez
vous avez le sentiment d'avoir assez
communiqué sur ce que vous allez
proposer
je pense que je pense que oui évidemment
à la petite échelle va pas dire qu'on a
mal travaillé
je pense que c'est vrai que c'est une
nouvelle comme une question quand même
vraiment de s'abstraire en fait c'est un
petit peu ça quand on y croit trottoir
une fête de la science d'accord mais
quelle science quoi faire c'est vrai que
nous fait une communication un peu de
dernière minute au qu'en fait c'est
vraiment dans les 50 derniers jours
qu'on a un affichage vraiment à l'eau
calcaire important parce que c'est quand
même des manifestations qui seront dans
la vie vous l entourent mais pas sur un
périmètre de 40 kilomètres je pense pas
et donc après effectivement c'est une
information qui est relayée par un
affichage donc les gens d'entendre
parler comme amiens m'ont volé moi je
pense mais la science ça reste aussi
abstrait pour les gens pour grand public
par exemple ce que vous faites à l'eau
véhicules observatoire de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines parce que ça
parle aux gens je pense que ça parle aux
gens en tout cas ça attire les gens ça
c'est sûr je pense que oui ça reste
abstrait c'est à dire quand les gens
viennent découvrir les laboratoires
effectivement ils ont très envie ils
sont très attirés et quand ils
ressortent effectivement ils ont tous en
règle générale le même mot qui est là là
je n'avais pas idée qu'on faisait de
telles choses si près de chez moi dans
mon territoire et effectivement ça sert
à ça la fête de la science au vélo v est
ce que justement l'observatoire de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
alors loveth qu en fait ouvre ses portes
aux scolaires donc aujourd'hui demain et
vendredi
on ouvre deux laboratoires en fait le
latmos et de ces arcs fait quoi dans ses
laboratoires alors quotidien au
quotidien en fait le latmos c'est le
laboratoire atmosphères milieux
observations donc ce sont des
scientifiques et des chercheurs qui
travaillent sur un réseau très très
divers d'un d'instruments spatiaux des
instruments qui partent en orbite qui
volent etc
il ya également l'instrument sam que
on commence à connaître qui a embarqué à
bord de curiosity donc en fait on ouvre
on ouvre tous ses laboratoires ses
terres que les chercheurs et les
scientifiques ouvrent leurs laboratoires
font des ateliers d'à peu près une demi
heure 40 minutes et essaye de vulgariser
évidemment ce qu'ils font auprès du
grand public toujours évident pour
scientifique de volume c'est pas
toujours évident ouais ça après ça
dépend de tout un chacun de la façon
dont il aborde son sujet des veillées se
soient accessibles justement alors on
essaye en fait cette année la grande
nouveauté c'est qu'on ouvre toute la
journée de samedi des ateliers qui sont
vraiment dédié aux enfants
parce qu'effectivement quand on ouvre
nos portes et qu'on a un groupe de 20
personnes avec des adultes des enfants
etc
là c'est très compliqué pour le
scientifique de s'adapte à son public de
classe cette année on a des ateliers qui
s'adresse aux 6 11 ans samedi toute la
journée et là le scientifique va
s'adapter à un public jeune et réadapté
tout à fait son sujet et puis dimanche
comme tous les ans on est ouvert toute
la journée pour les familles les adultes
les portes sont ouvertes et on a le
latmos d'une part et le sait a requis à
un autre laboratoire qui ouvre également
qui ouvre également ses portes qui est
plus sûr là le développement durable est
l'impact en fait du changement
climatique sur l'eau et les populations
ce qui l'intéressé c'est un mur de la
maison de l'environnement du
développement durable et des sciences
aussi parce qu'on oublie souvent
l'appellation complète la dénomination
complète de l'établissement
vous aussi vous allez veiller à
vulgariser au maximum pour le grand
public et pour les enfants
excuser notre programmation va
s'adresser aussi aux plus jeunes oui
alors donc nous on est déjà l'une
médiation scientifique
mon côté au quotidien donc là on a une
programmation qui où il ya des actions à
la fois dans les murs et hors les murs
donc à la fois au centre commercial on a
une action le samedi toute la journée
donc c'est là c'est vraiment une action
grand public pas seulement pour les
enfants en général ont l'âme à des
ateliers qui sont très dynamiques et
donc en général sur les enfants qui
attire qui veulent venir voir et qui
entraîne les parents tant mieux c'est
c'est très bien on a en fait plusieurs
intervenants à ce moment là et après on
a le grand village des sciences qui se
trouve au sein de la maison de
l'environnement où on accueille en fait
différents acteurs du territoire
nous on a choisi d'aborder la thématique
de l'eau pour s'aligner un petit peu sur
la tête de l'unesco voilà exactement la
une international la coopération dans le
domaine de l'eau et par ailleurs cette
année pour la première fois on va
intégrer aussi le grand village des
sciences du plateau de saclay où on a
aussi un stand où on présente là-bas un
jeu qu'on a développée avec les ps on en
phase en ce moment deux prototypes car
je de valorisation sur la qualité de
l'air intérieur est donc à ce titre là
on rejoint en tête nos autres homologues
scientifique et l'eau justement j'en
profite juste pour vous préciser que
c'est le thème de notre magazine
environnement le magazine environnement
de la rédaction équilibre à voir
actuellement sur notre antenne ou à
consulter en replay sur le site internet
on va continuer à parler de vos
programmations dans le cadre de cette
fête de la science
on va juste revenir sur l'un des rendez
vous qui était proposée dès aujourd'hui
par l'omvs qu reportage de yolaine
thorez et de patrick jacques de dixmude
ces lycéens scientifiques viennent de
finlande ce mercredi dans le cadre de la
fête de la science à guyancourt
il découvre les dernières actualités de
la planète mars
ce professeur leur présente les récents
résultats de l'exploration menée sur la
planète rouge grâce à curiosity un
appareil envoyée par la nasa
actuellement donc nous sommes en train
de rouler sur mars
donc c'est intéressant curiosité c'est
un véhicule qui donc fait 900 kg qui se
déplace sur mars pour au moins deux ans
et qui va analyser le sol de mars
l'atmosphère de mars avec 10 appareils
de mesures différent d'un thème d'un de
ses responsables
il nous livre l'une de ses dernières
découvertes de l'eau aurait coulé sur
mars sans doute en abondance il y à
quelques milliards d'années
les élèves ont ensuite visité les
laboratoires de l'unité de recherche
autre atelier scientifique proposé ce
mercredi le jardin partagé cette fois ci
pour les plus petits aussi des
confitures
c'est une langue très propre et
d'ukraine on propose en fait des
ateliers pour les petits et pour les
grands dons d'une demi-heure à une heure
tout le monde peut s'initier au
jardinage et échanger sur des pratiques
respectueuses de l'environnement et voir
que les légumes sortent bien de terre et
pas des supermarchés une activité
proposée à nouveau vendredi et samedi
prochain sur réservation la fête de la
science continue jusqu'à dimanche
ateliers expositions conférences et
spectacles sont au programme
la science c'est parfois tout btan c'est
juste ses légumes qui poussent dans les
jardins et pas dans les supermarchés il
faut prendre les choses à la base quel
bilan on peut faire de l'opération qui a
été menée aujourd'hui pour l'instant
balle bilan est très positif les enfants
sont très intéressés c'est un programme
très ludique
c'est le jardin lieu de ville au lieu de
partage donc je pense que la fête de la
science ça sert aussi à faire passer un
tas de messages de ce genre et marie
cousin a très bien défini la
problématique qui est bas les légumes ne
pose pas un supermarché il ya plein de
il ya plein de choses aussi à faire
autour de ça donc on attend encore
beaucoup d'enfants notamment samedi on a
des scolaires vendredi autour du jardin
partagé donc on attend vraiment quelque
chose de très ludique il ya vraiment un
partage en fait la science c'est aussi
simple que ça en fait c'est tout
bêtement par des légumes au jardin c'est
aussi ce que vous faites au quotidien la
maison de l'environnement
les plus jeunes oui voilà donc nous
c'est vraiment une sensibilisation à la
démarche scientifique
donc on peut poser des questions c'est
très bien leurs skis
l'omvs qui pardon pardon je vais arriver
que lors de la moins de la fête de la
science mais c'est vrai que après c'est
ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est de
voir d'avoir des ateliers vraiment
adapté aux tout jeunes publics permettre
vraiment de pouvoir amorcer une démarche
expérimentale sur une courte période
d'une heure et pouvoir le mettre en
parallèle d'un travail expérimental qui
fait un laboratoire et cela en échange
entre vos deux établissements au cours
de l'année parce que là on parle de
cette fête de la science on voit les
initiatives qui sont menées pour
intéresser le jeune public mais ça doit
se traduire aussi au quotidien
alors pour l'instant on n'a pas encore
mené de projets c'est l'occasion
mais justement en fait on coulisses ou
d'en parler pour l'année prochaine voilà
exactement la suite au tragique épisode
avant tellement travaillé ensemble vous
reviendra sur ce plateau pour en parler
on s'intéresse encore un petit peu à vos
programmes respectifs le concernant la
maison de l'environnement on le voit
vous passez par d'autres d'autres modes
aussi opératoire il ya un cabaret
politique sur l'eau par exemple voilà
dans tout accueillons en fait à cadrer
politique où on réunit des personnes
différents donc y'a un scientifique un
poète qui est là on va avoir aussi la
visite du directeur régional de la
recherche et de la technologie je viens
de l'apprendre cet après midi donc on
est ravi de cet échange convivial avec
le public
il y aura beaucoup d'événements qui sont
proposés et concernant l'eau vaincu s'il
ya un événement à ne pas manquer au
cours du week-end si fort choisir si on
peut pas tout faire si on veut se rendre
et à la maison de l'environnement réel
obs q qu'est ce qu'on choisit ont choisi
la journée de dimanche en famille voilà
je pense que c'est vraiment le la
journée la plus longue il y aura le plus
de laboratoire ouvert beaucoup
d'ateliers donc si on veut faire une
sortie en famille c'est dimanche de 10
heures à 18 heures pour les plus jeunes
à partir de les plus jeunes ce serait
plutôt samedi à partir de quel âge 6,2 à
partir de 6 ans la porte sur six ont
suffisamment d'attention rien précédent
difficile et effectivement c'est encore
plus abstraite pour eux merci à toutes
les deux être unique marc laisné de
cette fête de la science jusqu'au 13
octobre et puis les programmes complets
sont à consulter sur le site internet
qui se sont affichés je mentionne aussi
qu'il ya des animations qui sont prévues
au cea de saclay cet organisme de
recherche sur les énergies nucléaire et
renouvelables samedi 12 octobre vous
pourrez découvrir le neurospin c'est une
installation unique dédié aux recherches
sur le cerveau et puis est le même jour
mais aussi le dimanche plusieurs
ateliers animés par des chercheurs au
gymnase du moulleau pour comprendre la
fabriquer des molécules ou encore le
pilotage d'un coeur de
réacteur voilà vous serez incollable en
sciences un frère culture à présent et
nous partons pour cuba dimanche dernier
le scarabée à la verrière accueillait
ibrahim ferrer junior fils du chanteur
du même nom célèbre pour avoir initié le
film buena vista social club en 1997
entre deux airs de salsa et de boléro
nous l'avons rencontré cette artiste qui
marche sur les traces de son père et qui
figure parmi les plus populaires
d'amérique du sud et des caraïbes
la vie c'est l'amour et j'aime la vie
c'est pourquoi j'évoque quasiment
toujours l'amour dans mes chansons
le public français est un public
merveilleux c'est la troisième ou
quatrième fois je crois que je viens
dans ce pays pour participer à
différents festivals et à chaque fois il
ya beaucoup de sympathie et de tendresse
il ya un échange à chaque fois entre le
public et moi c'est merveilleux je pense
que le public français est phénoménal
avec le sourire toujours et brême ferrer
juniors du spectacle cinéma 9 mois ferme
c'est le nom du nouveau film de et avec
albert dupontel l'histoire d'une juge de
40 ans célibataire mais enceinte campé
par une sandrine kiberlain amnésique et
qui peine à s'expliquer la situation le
père est en effet un dangereux criminel
reste donc à caen plus comprendre
comment l'impensable est arrivé une
comédie sion les écrans le 16 octobre en
avant première vendredi 11 octobre au
cirano à versailles le réalisateur
albert dupontel sera présent je vous
laisse découvrir cette bande annonce
avant d'aller rencontrer le réalisateur
à versailles vendredi
je m'appelle l'ariane felder j'ai 40 ans
je suis juge d'instruction célibataire
et sans enfant son blog
non je suis une femme intelligente
non c'est pas possible
la fécondation et lieu il ya environ six
mois
à
le quartier du palais de justice le soir
du 31 décembre la tête elles
maintiennent bona
on valide hors stade et face votre
caméra ça suffit on a rsa j'ai une bonne
nouvelle on a frôlé le maire multiples
et déjà fiché accusé d'une agression
assez intéressant bien il a bouffé les
yeux jour il pas peur n'aie pas peur
panique mais non je mange pas les yeux
des gens n'est pas propre on va en voir
si bien compris est une très bonne juge
assez m'intéresse alors histoire
d'agression et de bouffer ses yeux j'y
suis pour rien c'est un accident il ça
fait trois semaines qu'elle fait pipi
c'est un énorme chèque qui faisait noir
en conduisant son pipi tous les trois
jours ils partent en l'air
quelqu'un qui pourrait la ligue est à la
fois gagner avec les experts et même
très bête
le tribunal vous condamne à l'expulsion
l'autre là le père j'ai pensé au père il
est tard y est débile si vous entendez
exécution immédiate
et eto'o
tu perds tu pleures mais mettra pas
bouffer voilà
neuf mois ferme à découvrir dès le 11
octobre à versailles avec le réalisateur
qui sera présent en football l'équipe de
france qui se prépare actuellement à
clairefontaine dans les yvelines pour
une double confrontation face à
l'australie ce vendredi en amical et
mardi prochain pour le dernier match de
qualification face à la finlande
cette semaine le parisien blaise matudi
à retrouver son ancien coéquipier
mamadou sakho désormais joueur de
liverpool en angleterre le défenseur
central formé au psg cet exilé
outre-manche pour retrouver du temps de
jeu couper le cordon avec le psg aussi
il a également mentionné le niveau de la
première league anglaise ce matin lors
de la conférence de presse anthony rech
et étaient présents forcément j'ai voulu
casser justement ce truc là avec paris
pour pour prouver montré que à partir du
moment où mon travail n'était pas
récompensé ben j'ai préféré prendre une
décision et l'assumé j'ai vraiment
ressenti que le football était vécue
d'une façon différente en angleterre par
par les supporters par la ville entière
quand les genres pour jour la vie active
et si vous n'étiez avec nous au début de
ce journal je vous propose de re
découvrir l'image du jour dédié les
librairies le pavé du canal à montigny
le bretonneux l'établissement existe
depuis 24 ans son futur pose question
développement des ventes sur internet
concurrence des grandes surfaces
et puis également un coût des loyers en
centre ville la situation pousse son
propriétaire a organisé mercredi
prochain à 19h un rendez vous autour de
son avenir au tour de l'avenir de
l'établissement il sera aussi question
de reprise seriez vous prêt à vous
lancer dans cette aventure nous
recevrons le directeur de pavés du canal
de montigny-le-bretonneux cours de nos
prochaines éditions pour faire le point
avec lui c'est la fin de ce journal a
retrouvé en replay sur notre site
internet accessible également depuis
votre smartphone je vous retrouve demain
dès 18 heures toujours en direct
n'oubliez pas ce mercredi soir le rendez
vous culturel de la rédaction kiosque
présenté par aurélia de bissy kiosque
spéciale consacrée aux 20 ans de déclic
théâtre avec de nombreuses images
inédites à découvrir de ceux qui ont
fait leurs débuts à trappes et qui sont
aujourd'hui des vedettes nationales et
même quelquefois internationale je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée à demain